joining us now from perthshire is
scotland's deputy first minister john
swinney thank you very much for being
on the programme uh today um starting
off on covid and nicola sturgeon's got
much better approval ratings than boris
johnson
for the way that she's dealt with the
covert crisis but actually if you look
at the recent data from the office of
national statistics
national records of scotland
proportionately more people have been
dying with covert in scotland than
england so
is nicola sturgeon let off the hook i
think if you look back over the whole
of the pandemic what you see is that the
number of cases in scotland has been
about 30 percent less than it's been in
england and in wales so i think we've
seen a comparatively
lower level of the prevalence of the
virus and obviously we've taken
different measures to try to tackle the
situation
within scotland but i think when we're
dealing with
a pandemic dealing with the fact that
people's lives are affected and some
lives
tragically are lost i think it's
important to focus on the fact that
we're doing everything we possibly can
do
in the best possible way to try to
protect the population and that's been
the approach that we've taken as a
government
i'm a bit confused at the first part of
your answer there saying that there's
been fewer cases in scotland and
it's not a great thing is it if you've
got fewer cases but more people are
dying
well obviously the effective covert will
will
affect the the underlying health of
people within a particular
in society are unhealthier than people
in england well obviously there are
challenges that
people will have with underlying health
conditions that will vary from
individual to individual around the
society but in general
the case the cases that have presented
themselves in scotland
have been about 30 lower than in the
rest of the united kingdom
and what we're trying to do in all that
we do on a weekly basis
is to minimize the prevalence of the
virus to reduce the cases and we're
seeing
steadily a reduction in the number of
cases where we're now
seeing cases per 100 000 in scotland
being
around about 120 and that's come down
quite significantly in the course of the
last few weeks we've been taking
measures
to reduce the prevalence of the virus
there's been an awful lot of
conversations and debate about what
happens at christmas but of course new
year or hogmanay in scotland is a really
big celebration for
many families as well are you worried
that people might ignore the rules and
get together to celebrate it's been a
really difficult one for us i have to
say
sophie it's i think all of us are very
nervous
about the christmas period we obviously
understand that everybody will be
feeling a sense of
desperation almost to be with our
families and
to to have more social interaction with
those that they love
and obviously in scotland we have the
added dimension that there's a lot of
socializing around about
hagmoney but what we've decided to do is
to agree a limited amount of extra
social interaction around about
christmas
and unfortunately say to people for hug
money we're just gonna have to
stick at home and not have that social
interaction
and that'll be difficult this year but
what i would appeal to people to do is
to to recognize that
it's this year we're seeing um improved
prospects of tackling the virus with the
reductions in caseload or the the
arrival of the vaccine that gives us
some hope that
maybe by next hug money we can enjoy it
as we normally do
fingers crossed for next year certainly
we hope that by then we'll be able to
have a bit of a return to normality now
the smp's westminster leader in
blackfood has apologized after tweeting
a photographer called orly taylor who
posted a picture from the highlands i'm
sure you've seen the coverage he tweeted
saying as you live in the south of
england
and travel to scotland there's only for
permitted reasons i'm sure there will be
a valid reason as to why you're posting
a photo from the north of scotland last
night now
of course it then transpired that ollie
taylor actually lives about five minutes
away from where he took the photo
isn't that an example of you know the
worst kind of covered snooping
think it was a mistake by ian and he
acknowledged that and he apologized for
it
and i think what it it demonstrates is
that there's
a lot of anxiety about and where there
can be movement around
society which can lead to the spread of
the virus and
i suppose all i would say is that it's
really important that all of us
minimize our social interaction and
minimize our traveling around the
country because that's what the virus is
searching out for it searching out for
people moving from
areas of high prevalence to low
prevalence and the spread of the virus
and
we we've gone for a tiered system in
scotland for some weeks now where
the highlands is in a much lower set of
restrictions
than in the central belt or in very
large parts of
of england as well so what we're trying
to do is to make sure that people where
there is a low prevalence
are able to experience as much of life
as they possibly can do
and to keep virus levels at a low level
now that's a challenge
where you have some degree of social
interaction and moving around even in
areas like the highlands
and so i think if people follow the
rules then it makes it a lot
safer and a lot more reassuring for
everybody else
although of course important to say that
ollie taylor it seems was
following the rules um well absolutely
i'm sorry please please
don't don't i i completely accept what
you're putting to me and i wouldn't want
to suggest otherwise
but just as a general observation the
more we minimize our travel
the better it is for minimizing the
spread of the virus yeah understood
understood
um i'm keen to talk about uh alex
salmond the the scottish parliament has
voted twice
to force the scottish government to
release the legal advice that it
received in relation to that trial
you've refused twice why are you
ignoring the will of the scottish
parliament
well i've not refused twice what i've
said what the
the government's original position was
that we do not
to release legal advice and no
government releases
legal advice except in in very
exceptional circumstances now what i've
said to parliament
is that we will consider the fact that
parliament has voted in that way
that consideration is ongoing at the
present moment and that work is being
undertaken to determine
whether what approach we should take to
responding to the votes that parliament
has undertaken so
the issue's not closed it's very much
under active consideration within the
scottish government
and i'll update parliament as soon as
i've got to a conclusion on the handling
of that issue
so to be clear you might you may very
well publish that advice
well there's a possibility that we might
do that because parliament has asked us
to do that and i'm now reflecting on
that particular issue so
at no stage have i closed the door on
this issue i've simply set out the fact
that the government
ordinarily and that when we're not
unusual in this respect governments
don't publish their legal advice and
indeed
the ministerial code under which i
operate indicates that i'm not allowed
under the ministerial code
other than in exceptional circumstances
to release legal advice and i need the
prior consent
of our law officers before i do that so
the rules are quite clear that i
shouldn't be releasing the legal advice
but parliament has obviously voted for
that to be the case and i've said to
parliament
i'm considering that issue so i've not
closed the door and it's under very
active consideration
um active consideration when are you
likely to make a decision
well we'll have to move out quite soon
on this because obviously i understand
the committee has
um it's got its own work program to take
forward and we've cooperated fully with
the committee we've sent
thousands of pages of documents to the
committee that are looking at this issue
and i want to continue that cooperation
so i'm mindful of the fact that the
committee
wants to have that information to enable
it to complete its work and
and we're working as swiftly as we can
to address those issues
okay thank you very much for coming on
the show and sending out and some of
that much appreciated good
talk